make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and uh
make sure you guys hit the like button
if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to comics explained and
with daredevil slated to appear in
she-hulk over the course of the next 30
minutes i'm going to make you an expert
on the character which by the way yes we
do have a daredevil explained video but
that was made seven years ago and a lot
has happened in between so daredevil was
created by stan lee and bill everett
with some input from jack kirby and
first appeared in daredevil number one
in 1964. now according to stan lee
daredevil was the product of wanting to
come up with a title for bill ever to
work on because he wasn't really doing
anything at the time which is really
kind of crazy because bill everett this
guy was a legend in comics this guy
actually created a name on the
submariner so he had basically been
contributing to the comic book scene
since the 1940s and so while stan lee
was fleshing out the idea of daredevil
he decided that he needed to have some
kind of flaw because he'd read several
articles that the flawed natures of
marvel superheroes were actually what
drew readers to them and that's a true
statement that's one of the things that
i want to focus on here that's a true
statement when it came to mobile comics
back in the 1960s 1970s what really
interested people when it came to their
characters specifically somebody like
the fantastic four or peter parker was
the fallible nature of them instead of
how you saw superman or batman in the
1950s which is that they always seem to
do the right thing arguably that when it
came to the fantastic four like they
bickered amongst each other the same way
that families normally do that when it
came to spider-man he was a kid that
just couldn't catch a break and so this
sort of relatability when it came to
superheroes drew a lot of interest for
people who were reading marvel comics at
the time and so in daredevil's initial
appearances his costume which was
designed by bill everett was yellow and
red and he basically carried billy clubs
which was apparently an idea attributed
to jack kirby that remains a signature
part of the character even today now the
yellow and red costume proved to be
exceedingly unpopular with the staff of
marvel and so stan lee suggested a
change to an all red costume which
resulted in artist wally wood
redesigning the suit to the iconic look
that daredevil has basically kept
throughout the entirety of his history
and so as for daredevil's comic book
origin matt murdock basically grew up in
the hell's kitchen neighborhood of new
york the son of a semi-famous boxer
named battling jack murdock who really
never wanted his son to have to make a
living with his fists and insisted that
he devote himself to his studies and so
one day matt sees an elderly man
crossing the street about to be run over
by a truck and he pushes the guy out of
the way now it turns out the truck was
carrying radioactive materials that
splashed into matt murdock's face and
basically blinded him something else
that i want to point out here because
undoubtedly somebody's going to bring it
up in the comments section if i don't
that there is apparently a confirmed
crossover between daredevil and the
teenage mutant ninja turtles that the
toxin that was on that truck and
splashed into the eyes of matt murdock
actually rolled down into the sewers of
new york and that's how you got the
teenage mutant ninja turtles but in any
event with matt being blinded his other
senses end up becoming extremely
heightened to the point that they mimic
a radar-like sense that basically copies
his sense of sight now when battling
jack becomes desperate for money he
starts work with a crime boss known as
the fixer and then begins throwing
fights for money and so when matt comes
to one of the fights as a young man jack
refuses to take a dive and the fixer
ultimately has him killed and so
remembering his promise to his father
not to resort to violence matt adopts
the costumed alter ego known as
daredevil and basically takes revenge on
his father's killers by turning to
violence so much for promises being kept
but years later matt would graduate from
columbia law school and basically live
out a double life as a lawyer by day and
a vigilante by night now stanley
continued to write dear devil for nearly
five years leaving the title with issue
number 50 in 1969 and during his run
stan worked with a variety of artists
which included bill everett and wally
wood and even john romita senior but his
most frequent collaborator was gene
cullen who took over penciling duties
with issue number 20 and remained on the
title until lee's exit but during lee's
run most of daredevil's supporting
characters were introduced most notably
his girlfriend karen page and his lawyer
partner foggy nelson along with several
members of his rogues gallery like the
owl the purple man stiltman and even
gladiator but following lee's departure
daredevil was written by some iconic
names in the comic book industry which
included roy thomas yuri conway steve
gerber marv wolfman and even jim shooter
and although some of the introductions
in that time included bullseye which was
of course one of daredevil's arch
nemesis none of these runs gained a
whole lot of traction with fans now
there is a reason for that and that's
one of the things that i want to specify
here if we look at somebody like jerry
conway for example jerry's run in
hindsight is considered one of the more
interesting runs of daredevil but at the
time it was rejected by a lot of
daredevil fans and the reason why is
because one of the things that conway
had done had been to actually move
daredevil from new york to san francisco
and people didn't like that people
really were not a huge fan of that they
ultimately saw that daredevil was born
and bred in the city of new york and
even beyond that it was one of those
situations where people looked at the
character of daredevil and saw that with
him being in the city of new york itself
it put him in closer proximity to a lot
of the other superheroes that existed
there and so by removing him from new
york and putting him in san francisco
the different crossovers that we'd seen
with his character just didn't quite
seem to happen all that much and in fact
it made fans feel like daredevil was
basically an outlier but in any event
frank miller ultimately took over as the
penciller on daredevil with issue number
158 1979 and at the time the book was
actually being written by roger mckenzie
who up to that point was really best
known for his work on horror titles so
vampirella and creepy and eerie and
different things like that and what
roger mckenzie had tried to do was
basically blend the horror element of
his historical works with daredevil
which was not overly well received and
so what this led to was the book's
editor dennis o'neil ultimately firing
mckenzie so that frank miller could both
write and draw the title beginning with
daredevil issue number 168 in 1980. now
this proved to be perhaps the biggest
moment in the history of daredevil
comics because frank miller is
responsible for a huge chunk of the
daredevil mythos and even according to
jim shooter the book's popularity
greatly increased during miller's run
and he even predicted that had frank
miller not taken over the book would
have soon been cancelled and this is an
accurate statement because oftentimes
whenever we're talking about the
different writers that contribute to
marvel comics we do talk about stan lee
but one of the things we talk about is
how a lot of other writers are usually
overlooked because of stan lee that stan
lee's kind of the face of marvel comics
but guys like roy thomas and guys like
marv wolfman and people like jerry
conway frank miller and chris claremont
all had massive contributions but one of
the funny things is a lot of the work
that chris claremont did in his handling
of the x-men title focusing on turning
it into a soap opera as opposed to just
focusing on the pretty white kids with
problems type of storytelling that stan
lee jack kirby arnold drake and roy
thomas focused on is that it was heavily
influenced by the work of frank miller
his work on daredevil influenced the
work of chris claremont and the reason
for this is one of the first things that
frank miller did was make huge changes
to daredevil's origin instead of being a
down on his luck fighter that had turned
to fixing fights out of desperation to
support his son battling jack murdock
was depicted as an abusive alcoholic now
frank miller had also introduced the
character of stick who was a blind
martial arts master that had trained
daredevil shortly before he lost a sight
in daredevil issue 176. now one of the
things that i want to point out here is
that while we look back at frank
miller's writing in hindsight and say
this is definitively the single greatest
daredevil run that there's ever been it
was not without controversy one of the
big controversies was the adjustment
that was made to battling jack murdock
that at the time people saw battling
jack murdock as a guy who fixed fights
and that one of the things people loved
the most about battling jack murdock's
death was the fact that he died as a
result of refusing to fix fights which
basically showed that people could be
redeemed that was again heavily
influential on matt murdock in the idea
that not everybody was without saving
when it came to frank miller changing
that and not just altering that origin
of battling jack but actually turning
him into a guy that basically beat on
matt murdock himself there was a subsect
of the daredevil fan base that holy
rejected it they absolutely despised
that adjustment to the character but
another change that frank miller had
made is that he introduced daredevil's
most iconic supporting character in the
form of elektra nachios in daredevil
issue 168 the first issue that he
started on now since her introduction
elektra has been used as an ally an
enemy and a love interest at various
times and she would become so popular
during the frank miller run that she
would actually star in her own solo
series shortly after debuting and met
matt murdock at columbia university and
the two began dating but after she and
her father are kidnapped and her
father's killed elektra goes to china
and she meets stick who trains her and
tries to neutralize the darkness that's
inside of her but she ends up joining an
ancient sect of evil known as the hand
now the hand was another huge
introduction during frank miller's run
and their significance cannot be
overstated now the hand which debuted in
daredevil issue 174 are a centuries-old
clan of ninja assassins that are devoted
to the service of an entity known as the
great evil beast now stick who of course
again was the guy that trained both
daredevil and elektra leads a group
known as the cast which is basically his
own kind of antithesis to the hand
themselves in order to face off and
defeat the hand now although elektra
does eventually defect from the hand and
then battle them alongside daredevil the
hand has been one of daredevil's
fiercest and most frequent foes ever
since their introduction and in fact the
hand has historically been so popular in
marvel comics that other characters from
marvel were rolled over to be involved
with the hand a really good example of
this was the enemy of the state
storyline with wolverine where wolverine
was basically kidnapped by the hand and
hydra working together in order to
brainwash him and then send him out into
the world to kill differing superheroes
and in fact that story was so popular
that marvel wrote a what if story where
what if wolverine had succeeded which
basically ended up becoming the story
that i call wolverine kills the marvel
universe but miller's contribution to
daredevil's rogues gallery didn't simply
stop there and although he didn't create
him miller is responsible for pitting
daredevil against his arch nemesis the
kingpin wilson fisk now prior to
daredevil 170 in 1981 when kingpin first
appeared in a daredevil comic he was
considered a spider-man villain and he
had originally debuted in the amazing
spider-man number 50 in 1967 but during
frank miller's run on daredevil not only
did miller give the kingpin a real name
in the form of wilson fisk but he made
kingpin first and foremost a daredevil
villain to the point that kingpin is
hardly associated with spider-man
anymore and since that time kingpin and
daredevil have been constantly locked in
a power struggle for control of hell's
kitchen and new york city as a whole
that's still playing out in the pages of
daredevil today but frank miller
ultimately left the title with issue
number 191 in 1983 but returned in 1986
to craft one of daredevil's most famous
story arcs and a story arc that is
actually sharing the name with daredevil
season 3 which is born again now during
this run matt murdock's ex-girlfriend
karen page resurfaces as a drug addict
he loses his law license after being
falsely set up by the kingpin and he
reunites with his mother who he believed
to have been dead but now discovers is
simply living as a nun and so one of the
things that i want to specify here is
that this particular story in a lot of
ways draws parallels with frank miller's
work the dark knight returns and despite
the fact that it was written three years
before the dark knight returns heavily
influenced frank miller's run on that
particular batman story but one of the
things that i also want to solidify here
is that frank miller's run on daredevil
is considered landmark because while it
did take away the significance of matt
murdock becoming who he was as a result
of what could arguably be considered
battling jack murdock's sacrifice in a
lot of ways it humanized the character
it brought daredevil down to a place
where this was a guy that struggled with
some of the most difficult things there
were times when he almost killed people
over the course of that story and in
fact following the death of elektra at
the hands of bullseye in frank miller's
run daredevil almost killed bullseye now
the way that played out just kind of a
quick explanation here the way that
played out is the fight really the kind
of final fight there between daredevil
and bullseye had actually been building
up for quite some time and it happened
several times over the course of frank
miller's run but the death of elektra at
the hands of bullseye at the hands of
lester was basically the final straw
right it was the the nail in the coffin
and that because of the fact that
daredevil had actually saved bullseye on
a multitude of occasions bullseye didn't
want to be saved and so he ultimately
tried to stab daredevil which led to
matt murdock letting bullseye fall and
then of course he ended up being
paralyzed now that leads to like a game
of russian roulette between the two of
them but the general point that i'm
making here is that where stan lee and
bill everett had focused heavily on what
you could argue to be a more
lighthearted version of daredevil frank
miller's run was very dark and very
visceral and that's why people look at
it as the defining run that laid the
groundwork for everything we know about
daredevil as we see him written today
but following frank miller's second exit
from the book a year later daredevil
basically went through a few different
writers most notably ann necenti who
wrote the title for four and a half
years from 1987 to 1991. now frank
miller would revisit the character in
the 1983 mini-series daredevil the man
without fear alongside artist john
romita jr but the biggest development
post miller would actually come in 1998
when the daredevil title was rebooted
during the marvel knights publishing
initiative now this is something that
we've talked about before over the
course of marvel comics but i think it's
worth repeating here that while we don't
have to necessarily go into the
backstory as to why it happened the
reality is that in the mid-1990s marvel
was basically going bankrupt and so
marvel did a couple different things in
order to keep themselves from completely
going broke one of the first things they
did is they started licensing off the
film rights to characters that they
owned hence the reason why sony owned
the rights to the spider-man films for
so long and why fox owned the fantastic
four and the x-men but the thing about
this is what they also did is they
launched marvel knights now marvel
knights was an imprint that was actually
handed off from marvel comics to a
company called event publications which
was ran by jimmy palmiotti and joe
quesada and the way this worked is that
instead of marvel publishing these
stories in-house with their own writers
and their own artists which was an
incredibly expensive venture given the
fact that people wanted to be paid top
dollar that they could actually license
it out to event publications which would
have a cheaper roster of writers and
artists that would basically write
characters that marvel couldn't really
sell for a whole ton of money but made
some kind of money in effect event
publications was right in the characters
that marvel just couldn't justify paying
top dollar to create and so that's where
marvel knights came from but with joe
casada and paul miati handling the
penciling and the inking filmmaker kevin
smith was tapped to write the initial
daredevil story arc under the marvel
knights imprint and so while kevin smith
only wrote one eight issue arc of
daredevil the story arc guardian devil
remains a fan favorite and in this arc
which is an incredibly dark tone in a
lot of ways is a return to frank miller
this explored matt murdock's complicated
relationship with his catholic faith as
daredevil was forced to take care of an
infant that could either be a new
messiah or the antichrist now of course
kevin smith's story also sees the death
of karen page at the hands of bullseye
but this basically led us into the early
2000s when daredevils enjoyed some of
the most consistent good writing of any
marvel title with several critically
acclaimed runs on the character starting
with brian michael bendis taking over
the title with issue number 16 in 2001
and continuing until issue number 81 in
2006. now venice's run is still seen as
one of the best on daredevil due in
large part to the art of dave mack and
alex malev and an intensification of the
rivalry with kingpin which ultimately
sees daredevil's secret identity exposed
to the world but bendis's successor eric
brubaker stayed on the title until 2009
and his run was also a hit with critics
and fans alike now in 2012 writer mark
wade and artist chris samny took over
the title but by this time because
comics were consistently undoing things
that had basically been done daredevil's
identity is secret once again and he's
basically regained his law license
however by the end of the run he's
basically forced to reveal himself as
matt murdock yet again which basically
results in the state of new york
disbarring him which prompts matt
murdock to move across the country to
san diego now one of the things that i
want to specify here is that the reason
why things were being changed between
2010 and 2011 is because what you had in
this 10-year window between 2000 and
2010 is you had what was called the joe
casada era which has basically been met
by a combination of revile and fan
celebration it really depends on who
you're talking to and it depends on what
particular comic you're talking about
but joe casada coming on as
editor-in-chief in 2000 was basically
his reward for helping keeping marvel
afloat by having or by launching event
publications alongside jimmy palmiotti
and so that's why with jokasada's run
what you saw was the first five years as
editor-in-chief literally just breaking
everything down which was essentially
him going through and dismantling things
so getting rid of the marriage between
peter parker and mary jane watson and
spider-man one more day getting rid of
98
of the mutant population during house of
m initiating the superhero civil war the
death of captain america different
things along those lines and then for
the second half of that 10-year run it
was the rebuilding phase masai complex
messiah wars hope summers and the 10
lights all of which happen in the x-men
comics the launch of new avengers
different things along those lines but
in 2010 due to a series of controversies
specifically in captain america joe
casada was actually removed as
editor-in-chief he was elevated up to
chief creative officer so essentially
they said you can help with ideas but
you can't actually do anything and then
in his place as editor-in-chief came
axel alonso which actually initiated
something called the heroic age and the
heroic age is basically where everything
that people loved about jokasada's run
was continued on and everything that
people hated about jokasada's run was
basically eliminated the only real
exception being the marriage between
peter parker and mary jane watson but
having said all of that getting back
into daredevil itself i felt like that
kind of bit of history needed to be
explored matt murdock would ultimately
return to new york in 2015 under the
writing of charles soule who took over
the title as part of marvel's all-new
all different marvel initiative which
was one of several attempts by marvel to
boost sales and fan interest by
switching around creative teams but none
of which really had a cohesive direction
like marvel knights had and so
daredevil's identity would again become
secret once again thanks to the children
of the purple man who actually inherited
their father's ability to manipulate the
minds of others and use it to force
people to forget daredevil is matt
murdock but later in charles soule's run
matt murdock ends up finding himself as
deputy mayor of the city of new york and
the full-time mayor is none other than
wilson fisk but when fisk is attacked by
the hand matt has to assume the role of
mayor temporarily now the reason why
this happened this is actually one of
the cooler elements of marvel comics is
what you have was a story called secret
empire which is still one of my favorite
stories of all time but in effect the
red skull has gotten his hands on a
cosmic cube and used it to alter the
entire backstory of captain america so
that instead of steve rogers being a guy
who really wanted to fight against the
axis powers in world war ii getting the
super soldier serum and the rest just
simply being history that instead he had
basically always been a hydra agent and
so when he became captain america he had
secretly been working behind the scenes
to orchestrate a takeover of hydra which
he successfully did they actually ended
up conquering north america and then he
had his side set on the rest of the
world but during this story one of the
ways in which he basically started
removing superheroes from basically his
path to taking over north america
is he had a villain basically blanket
the city of new york and dark force
energy essentially new york was just cut
off from the rest of the world and
encased in darkness and so while you did
have the superhero specifically dagger
who was a superhero that had the ability
to emanate light while you did have her
alongside the other superheroes trying
to find a way out wilson fisk was
actually the one on the ground level
keeping the average person safe from
just general petty criminals and other
criminals who were going through and
trying to capitalize on the lawlessness
and so that's why when secret empire
came to an end wilson fisk was elected
as mayor because the people saw him as
their actual champion as opposed to the
avengers none of whom were protecting
them from just ground level criminals
and so at the moment the current writer
of daredevil is chip zadarski who took
over the title in 2019. now zadarski's
run actually started with daredevil
accidentally beating a criminal so badly
that he killed him and then he
subsequently turns himself over to the
cops and then basically goes to prison
but not as matt murdock but as the
costume vigilante daredevil and so with
matt murdock in prison elektra ends up
taking up the mantle of daredevil and
defends hell's kitchen from crime and
does so according to matt's code of no
killing which of course is at odds with
her long-standing history as an assassin
now recently matt murdock's basically
been released from prison and both he
and elektra currently don the daredevil
costumes and simply fight crime side by
side but that's where we are with the
daredevil comics here in 2022 it's kind
of continuing that trend now how long
that's gonna go for we don't entirely
know and again there are some things
that i left out here for example there
was a point where daredevil's uh twin
brother was basically revealed or at
least had been accidentally created by
an inhuman that daredevil had actually
created an identity for himself at one
point in time but this inhuman not
realizing that he basically read this
journal of daredevil and then brought
matt murdock's alter ego to life and
then passed him off or at least matt
passed him off as his twin brother that
was ultimately undone but again you know
there were some things that had happened
that were a little questionable which is
normal when it comes to chemical
characters but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
you are now an expert on daredevil
go forth and join the conversations on
on matt murdock's character but thank
you all for watching and i will catch
you all later peace